proving three point shooter since his
tenure here in Houston and he's got some
moves from that three-point line
there's Adams who contributes a lot
that's usually in a new the West is the
little stuff this year but I think the
Rockets hold on still a Matt what do you
think I'll agree with you Kate
Haley there's a good possibility that
could happen west foot nice pass there's
how you get the open threes you got to
give it to somebody that's not covered
figure she'd make that right up you
mentioned that staff that's right
Westbrook inside for two
wouldn't be seven feet tall nowadays
because they measure you without tissue
so he just needs six Tests BP 610
Russell Westbrook
whoa can he run Chris Paul
trying to get around Piniella shoots it
over it that's never bothered Chris be a
difference about six second shot clock
game club artists working on Gallinari
will shoot over it
Russell Westbrook Lauren can't believe
I'll tell you what you get arrested on
the street there's Chris Paul a little
look at the rocky franchise that's how
you dunk it whatever was said at
halftime seems to be working rockets
foul has been called here's the
alley-oop harden to Westbrook Westbrook
comes in from the corner James season
cutting in what a great pass right there
for Westbrook let's do is catch it hit
him in a tough spot that was an
offensive foul right there
Benson very offensive
Westbrook faster
he's got choices Westbrook on the wings
they knew that
with the ball waiting for him and it
ends up with an easy basket at do this
Paul turns a corner Nala now he's open
mrs. long rebound not that to OKC
Chris Paul with a three difference of
about four seconds shot clock game clock
Russell Westbrook to the basket lays it
up and in he is so quick he's aboard
he's talking some trash there to Paisley
and I think he got teed up for it yeah
he sure did
fresh 14 Oh little travel right there
Chris puts it up and in
Gallinari down the five seconds on the
shot clock in and out long ago here
comes Chris Paul he's got friends
intruder for - and here comes Golden
State when a shooter at the Fulton state
Oklahoma City 22 and he throws it right
to Gordon that was good defense
[Music]
freeway right down the middle hammer
right there and that gets the credit pop
their feet Mia
[Applause]
so both teams now will be in the penalty
for the final 225 there's Chris Paul
with a 336 36 points Bacchus need a stop
Chris Paul little fade away jumper he
can get that whenever he wants well
rebound of the game
fix it into the corner PJ
five PJ and the balls kicked around a
little bit and Chris Paul ends up with
it there it is a three-pointer